[Music]
[Applause]
for that brief interval of a song the
entire world just melts away and that is
what always brings me back
[Applause]
[Music]
coming into Yale I knew there was a Yale
Ballroom team I emailed over the summer
I showed up to the first few lessons and
then from there it's pretty much been my
main activity here on campus as soon as
I started dancing with some of the
senior members of the team I knew that
those were the people that I wanted to
spend the next four years with
[Music]
there are about 40 members on the team
we're an entirely student-run
organization we don't have any
professional faculty or any sort of
advisor on our team it's all student run
so you want to step out out in August to
about September and that's mostly just
practice that's really a time for all of
us to learn from each other yeah that
works when someone doesn't know how to
do something we can always know we can
go to each other to be each other's
teachers and coaches
seven eight one two there's a huge
balancing act that we all try to juggle
as we're going through here you know
you've got the full day of classes and
coming home at the end of the day you
really are exhausted so it's the
question of why continue why do one more
thing that pushes you further okay one
more time it's because there's something
in you that connects to the music
there's something in you that connects
to another person and
that is what
helps helps you drive yourself forward
and everything else when you get to
refresh yourself through dance
here
[Music]
in other sports that I've done I never
get the sense that I can like stop
thinking but when we dance typically
like I don't remember anything else
besides us dancing
[Applause]
it's also
something that we provide to the Yale
community that they can all enjoy and
something new and something that's not
really focused on anymore you exist
entirely in that moment with the people
that you are creating with and
storytelling with that reinforces the
kind of community and the kind of bond
that we share off the dance floor
because we take off our dance shoes we
put on Street shoes we don't stop being
Partners For the Love of Dance For the
Love of Dance
all right